para mí
de vuelta a la carrera por la casa
blanca repartiendo mascarillas el
presidente de donald trump llegó a
florida para presumir su primer acto de
campaña fuera de washington después de
haber sido diagnosticado con kobe 19 su
médico informó que dio negativo en una
nueva prueba de coronavirus y agregó que
no puede contagiar a otros pero el
mandatario le dio otra interpretación
que dicen que soy inmune
me siento tan poderoso entraré a esa
multitud y besaré a todos
y dicen que eres inmune no sé por cuánto
tiempo algunas personas dicen que de por
vida donald trump llega en busca de
consolidar su victoria florida aporta 29
de los 270 votos electorales para poder
ganar la presidencia es uno de los que
más otorgan todo el país pero es
reconocido como un estado pendular es
decir que no se inclina siempre por el
mismo partido y por ello los candidatos
se esfuerzan en cortejar a sus votantes
joe biden también estará allí pero antes
llegó hasta ohio otro estado pendular el
candidato demócrata ha aumentado su
publicidad a medida que trump ha
reducido su presencia
ohio aporta 18 electores y aunque barack
obama los ganó todos en 2008 y 2012
camps se quedó con ellos en 2016
necesitamos revivir el espíritu del
bipartidismo en el país no habrá estados
azules ni estados rojos conmigo es un
eeuu trabajador demócratas y
republicanos ambos candidatos se mueven
a un ritmo marcado por lo que reflejan
las encuestas pero solo tienen tres
semanas antes de que se descubra quién
ocupará la oficina
los próximos cuatro años